[Music]
this morning on the dish the foods of
eastern europe may conjure up images of
potato and borscht and the cuisine isn't
as globally renowned as that of italy
and france but ukrainian chef and writer
olea hercules is working to change that
perception by tirelessly documenting the
recipes and food of her homeland and its
neighboring regions
mts taya has her story
olia hercules knows how to feed a crowd
at her pop-up in london she delights
diners with an array of ukrainian dishes
i'm super super excited to have you here
enjoy
but it's the humble and hearty dumpling
which captivates taste buds here and
more dumplings are coming
at her home kitchen in the british
capital she shows us the art of making
the perfect parcel so you grab this
corner first okay and then we just just
stick it here
so just like just yeah just like that
and then thank you that's not the most
beautiful dumpling ever made
hercules says her journey to chef and
cookbook author truly began when her
family moved from ukraine to cyprus when
she was just 12 years old later moving
to london she gave up a career in
journalism to work in some of the city's
best kitchens but it was the food of her
childhood which she wanted to share with
the world a lot of people do maybe see
eastern european food as quite
monolithic it's borscht it's dumpling
it's potatoes it's potatoes and cabbage
but clearly not i mean
you were able to write three cookbooks
about it right now exactly
2014 was supposed to be one of the
happiest years in hercules life she had
just signed her first book deal
but her joy soon turned to horror as
russian tanks rolled into eastern
ukraine not far from her parents home it
was the most terrifying time of my life
you know uh not a fearful person at all
but uh when that happened because
especially because my family just an
hour and a half away from crimea so
if it was to move forward you know would
be next so of course you know kind of
waking up it was it was terrifying it
was the worst time
for all of us i think
um
but
it also triggered something inside you
to want to preserve
something so personal to you which is
your family's recipes
yeah absolutely i don't know
stars aligned in a way that
the whole
first cookbook
deal
mamushka became a bestseller and won
major awards it was followed up with
caucuses a culinary journey through
georgia azerbaijan and beyond and now
hercules has a third cookbook which was
published this year called summer
kitchens
what they are um
one
room little houses which look very
similar to your main house
um and they're usually situated just a
few steps away you know in your yard and
this is where you'd cook during the
summer because it's cooler to do it
there is when all of the jars would come
out and all of your gluts like all of
the produce fruit and vegetables would
be fermented pickled etc so it's you
know a huge operation i was gonna say
this is a lot of work there you go
you've got this very special kind of
kitchen workshop and i wanted to look at
how ukraine is
very diverse but also united by this
tradition
so even though food up north and down
south may vary we have this summer
kitchen where all of the cooking is
being done
dumplings are at the heart of hercules
cooking like manti filled with lamb and
fenugreek
gulhelun from central asia bursting with
sweet potato and apricot on yogurt
then
there's her favorite
these are called varenike and what's
inside the berenike
so we've got potato
and
cheese
dills yeah
and i actually added a little bit of
spinach because i had to use it up so
you know it's traditional just with a
little bit
that is so good
i was not expecting such strong flavors
to come out of that what's it like when
your family's together and you're
preparing a meal and then sharing a meal
with each other
so
vast amounts of food and the huge
extended family would get together and
you know sometimes they'd be laughing
and sometimes they'd be crying and
sometimes some singing would happen and
you know
and i feel like i'm just forever chasing
that feeling and maybe that's why i
became a chef and a writer you know just
trying to
bring back all of the
emotions that that kind of situation
gave me when i was a kid
for cbs this morning saturday
london
she gave us such an insight into not
only the culture but you know a sense of
like longing for her homeland and she
just made me very hungry
[Laughter]
i heated up leftovers which are not
nearly as good as what she made
incredible yeah it's very very
good for you leftovers too we might have
fresh vegetables he likes in the morning